der vorführung im scharfen schuss in
hallen steig rund 1300 zuseher werden
erstmals mit dem leistungsspektrum des
österreichischen bundesheers direkt
konfrontiert einsatz die kapazitäten der
verschiedenen waffen zu sehen zu
bekommen auch verschiedenen
einsatzmöglichkeiten
es wurde uns gesagt dass hier viele
scharf geschossen wird hubschrauber
panzer granatenwerfer ist das ganze
system was österreich zu bieten hat und
wenn ich mir das feld so anschaue
erwarte ich mir schon meine wissen ich
mein ich habe noch nicht scharf
geschossen das habe ich noch nicht dass
wir haben wir beim bundesheer auch dass
das alles neu für mich und ich freue
mich darauf zu sehen ist der einsatz
verschiedener waffengattungen auch im
verbund und in vollster präzision eine
demonstration der leistungsfähigkeit die
jedes mal aufs neue exakt geplant werden
muss
es ist jedes jahr immer wieder ein
nervenkitzel eine anspannung natürlich
dass zum einen das natürlich passt von
der sicherheit letztlich auch so wie
heute das wetter dann haben wir hunderte
zuschauer das muss reibungslos über die
bühne gehen
das publikum die zuschauer ist jedes
jahr neu machen das für die jungen
gerade anwärter dieses jahres die sich
jedes jahr hinter nicht mehr neues sagen
wir sollen für sich diesen kadersoldaten
die möglichkeit dem diese bilder zu
sehen bilder von einsätzen die jederzeit
eintreten können
da wird ein klo dem aspekt sind zu
zeigen was wir heute noch können auf
grund verschiedener budgetären
rahmenbedingungen morgen dann nicht mehr
kann
[Musik]
die über 1000 besucherinnen und besucher
waren jedenfalls von dieser
demonstration beeindruckt ja es war viel
verantwortung ist mir vorgestellt hab
was mich positiv überrascht hat war das
sehen nicht nur die offensiven
fähigkeiten des bundes gezeigt haben
sondern auch andere möglichkeiten wie zb
selbst ihm oder die aufklärer drohnen
also das hat mich das sehr positiv
überrascht dass sie die handlungs
reichweite sehr gut dargestellt
und bei manchen hat diese vorführung ihr
verhältnis zum bund bisher nachhaltig
geändert verändert es ist interessanter
geworden sich verfestigt besser ich
würde mir jetzt überlegen mich zu
verpflichten
ich habe die matura abgeschlossen also
würde ich auch die chance aufzusteigen
ich würde mich auch auf längere zeit
verpflichten lassen dass solche
wichtigen veranstaltungen auch weiterhin
abgehalten werden können trotz der
aktuellen schwierigen finanziellen
situation zeigt sich
verteidigungsminister stallinger
optimistisch wir haben sich ein extra
auch wieder weil im rahmen der politik
sich jetzt einiges zum bundesheer